Administration is dumping out billions
and billions of dollars hundreds of
billions of dollars for wind and solar
the small town of Greeley Nebraska
suddenly was told they're going to get
this enormous wind farm and they wanted
many of the residents to sign 75-year
leases 75 years to turn over their land
so that they could put up these wind
farms and Trevor a friend of the show
was like something doesn't feel right
and saw me on an episode and said we're
doing a town hall but we can't find
people to talk about the other side of
the issue would you come so I flew to
Greeley Nebraska didn't do any
fundraising wasn't trying to become
famous this is about them in their town
and it was around three and a half hours
of a town hall where I sat down with the
residents and just talked about what are
wind turbines what does it do what is
this company going to do the funny thing
is the company building the wind farm
was there but they refused to engage
they refused to talk about it so when
questions came up like hey this is
tornado country the tornado comes
through and blows up this wind turbine
and projectiles go in every direction
and it goes through your house or your
barn
who cleans up